I do a few Sabrina questions for you
because they're coming in and I also
want to ask you there's a lot of
speculation right now there's some
social media posts
yeah people want to know jazz and Claire
does this mean you guys are instagrams
official what is Instagram official even
mean are you guys more than friends you
know when I first went up to Vancouver
you're essentially moving your URI they
pay you to be to be in Vancouver
basically and me and jazz and a few
other of the actors really just hit it
off and we would spend every day
together
okay so jazz is like my closest friend
right now your closest friend
you know work commune yeah you know yeah
she called you her favorite which I
thought was really cute yeah the
favorites favorite that's what we always
say the favorite thing yeah she's
everyone else's favorite but if I'm her
favorite then it's like I collect I can
deal with that
yeah what can you tell me about where
season two picks up there's there's
gonna be I don't know there's gonna be
some new exciting relationships that
blossom Oh in season two okay which is a
which I think the fans aren't gonna be
initially excited about but I think
they're gonna grow to love okay these
new relationships
I truly I'm sorry I know
and who you are so what if we start over
no more secrets this time does that mean
Harvey and Sabrina find other people uh
I don't even know what I'm officially
allowed to talk about I can say it if
you want yeah yeah yeah there's the
every character goes has um you know
meets new people and yeah do you think
Harvey ever comes to appreciate or
accept magic it's it's very hard for him
because of where he comes from in his
ancestry and and he starts to see that
it can also do good okay see at first
you know it's it's all evil to him right
praise Satan you know all that stuff but
then yeah then he starts to see some
miracles okay did we go darker in season
two yeah yeah no but now Sabrina's at
the academy she's fully a witch and she
is loving it yeah so we get to see a
little bit of that how does that affect
Sabrina and Harvey um well she tries to
come back to Baxter high and and there's
just some problems with beautiful witch
now you know and should fans hold out
hope Sabrina yeah yeah I think I think
um there's definitely hope for the for
the characters okay is there hope that
we'll get some the driver Arab music on
yes really
yeah yeah I actually really hear on both
sides actually they're both talking to
me like Mike on the music side they're
like hey man like whose email do I need
to send them some music or whatever and
I'm Michael I want to do it personally
yeah well and then on the other side one
of our producers and the creator of our
show have hit me at Bolson they're like
hey so if there's ever like a good
opportunity and you have a particular
song like we'd love to
I want it to be a perfect fit mm-hmm so
I've kind of been holding out a little
bit but I do see that being very strong
possibility but maybe part three and
four because part two is already shot
right it's pretty much all edited and
they're just putting the final 105 this
is so exciting
like that feels like that that's it no
we're coming up with ideas yeah there's
this a song that we called 105 but
that's not what it's gonna be called we
just called the session that okay and
it's gotta work on the show yeah it's
got this kind of like dark anyway today
you said 105 105 I feel like preacher
man would also go just because the whole
yeah yeah religious for sure yeah yeah
and actually the Roberto acquire su casa
Sabrina yeah actually really likes that
song well if it happens we're gonna say
we started this whole I have to call not
yeah I love it too more fan questions
these ones from Twitter before you wrap
up here Brian
nug-nug and ugh says fill in the blank
2019 is the year for 20 nights Robyn is
the year for balance yeah all right I
think it's also the year of vegetables
have you been doing it kinda no yeah
pretty good quickly we should do warming
a surf Friday night yes cuz that those
are so good
dude yeah I'm coming those veggies in
there yeah yeah yeah more veggies do you
guys cook at home you can do more of
like the things kind of introduced to me
a little bit more in Vancouver yeah that
I can break that I'm bringing back so
it's like to rock you a little bit do
you guys cook together you and jazz well
jazz will jazz we had come over and
she's she's cooked Faraci
what does she make vegetables yeah all
vegetables which was like money
[Music]